على الخطوط الأمامية في أوكرانيا ، كان
معروفًا لزملائه المقاتلين بأنه
يسوع التكتيكي بسبب شعره الطويل
ومعرفته العميقة بالكتاب المقدس لأمه
،
كان جوشوا جونز من مواليد جوشي تينيسي يبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا فقط
عندما قُتل في القتال في  شرق
أوكرانيا في أغسطس ، ظهر جواز سفره في
بطاقة الهوية العسكرية الأوكرانية على
قنوات التواصل الاجتماعي الروسية بعد فترة وجيزة ،
لكن لم يتم العثور على جثته
منذ ذلك الحين ، عمل المشرعون الأوكرانيون
ألكسندر تروشن وألكسندر كوفاليف
بلا كلل لاستعادة جثته
اليوم ، وهذا ما يحدث أخيرًا.
من المهم بالنسبة لك أن
تستعيد جثة جوشوا جونز ،
إنه نفس البطل بالنسبة لي مثل
جنودنا ، لذا يجب أن نجعل كل شيء
ممكنًا لإعادة جسده إلى
عائلته ،
نحن نقود إلى خط المواجهة في
زابارسيا ، نتوقف على طول الطريق إلى
الارتباط بالمخابرات العسكرية
في سيارة أخرى ، جلس جندي روسي
متخبطًا بسبب إطلاق سراحه اليوم
كجزء من مبادلة أكبر في 10
أوكرانيا  تم إطلاق سراحهم بالفعل ،
وتحدث المشرعون مع الضباط
لمراجعة الخطة مرة أخرى
، يتم وضع علم أبيض مؤقتًا
في لحظة
الانتقال ونحن مرة أخرى
هذه المرة إلى No Man's Land
، وقد تم الاتفاق على وقف إطلاق نار نادر لمدة ساعتين  من
كلا الجانبين والوقت هو الجوهر ،
لذلك وصلنا للتو إلى نقطة الالتقاء
التي ينتظرون الآن
وصول الروس
بالجثة ، ويستعد فريق من المحققين الشرعيين
للمهمة المقبلة ،
وهذا بقدر ما نحن عليه  يُسمح بالذهاب
الفعلي سيحدث التسليم بعيدًا
عن التل في
انتظار عودتهم ، إنه هادئ بشكل مخيف ،
فقط الأشجع يجرؤ على الخروج في
هذه الأجزاء
، يلتقط أحد أعضاء فريق النقل
لحظة إعادة جثة جوشوا جونز
إلى الأراضي الأوكرانية بينما
تنظر القوات الروسية
إنها اللحظة التي كانوا ينتظرون
فيها جونز الآن على بعد خطوة واحدة
من إعادته إلى عائلته
مرة أخرى في السيارة ، فقد أظهروا لنا أغراضه
الشخصية أه هذا صليب صديقه الشخصي
الذي كان يرتديه
لقد كان رجلاً متدينًا للغاية ، ما هو
شعورك في هذه اللحظة التي كنت
تعمل فيها من أجل هذا لفترة طويلة
لمحاولة إعادة جوشوا جونز إلى
أسرته ،
وشعورنا أننا
فخورون ببلدنا من فريقنا نحن
فخورون بالرئيس
و  نحن فخورون بأننا ننقذ
الأرواح لأنك تعلم أنه حتى عندما
يموت شخص ما استمرت عائلته
في المغادرة ولا يمكنهم المغادرة بشكل
طبيعي إذا علموا أنه ليس
لديهم مكان يأتون إليه من أجل ابنهم
بفضل جهودهم والدة جوشوا
ميستي  ستتاح لجوسيت في تينيسي
قريبًا فرصة لتوديع ابنها
جوشوا هل كان جنديًا كان
جنديًا مولودًا
، وقد سُمي بعد معركة أريحا
وأثبت أنه ترقى إلى
اسمه ببسالة
وأنا أشعر بالوزن.  من العالم
قد انطلق معي
اسمًا وحياة سوف
نتذكرها حتى نصف عالم بعيدًا
كلاريسا وارد CNN zapparisha Ukraine